what do you think you're most known for
your acting your music or the
controversy that's around you my love I
got a big mouth came out there I talked
to my heart I'm real you know I'm saying
whatever comes comes but my controversy
probably and it's not my fault I'm
trying to find my way in the world you
know I'm trying to be somebody instead
of just make money off everybody you
know I'm saying so I go down past that
haven't been traveled before and I
usually mess up but I learn you know I'm
saying I come back stronger I'm not
talking ignorant you know I'm saying so
I obviously put thought into what I do
so I think my mouth my car's versatile I
have not been out of the papers since
I've been since I joined Digital
Underground I've been in all you know
I'm saying it's never my name is not
something not uttered you know the
saying and that's good for me because I
don't want to be forgotten if I'm
forgotten then that means I'm
comfortable and that means I think
everything is okay my mother taught me
three things respect knowledge search
for knowledge is in a turtle eternal
journey that's like magnet cut the line
360 degrees behind knowledge always and
and she taught me to not be quiet too if
there's something I mind speaking that's
what God I was a breath she always
taught but also to listen and chill is
he talking this little joke that God
gave you two ears to listen and one
mouth to speak to ears and one mouth
commonsense one month you should speak
but your souls will listen and that's
where the knowledge comes from listening
and once you get the knowledge and you
can speak and it helps you so she taught
me respect knowledge and understanding
mostly you know just know you just
watched two amazing clips of Tupac
Shakur take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]